Recall from our last video
that it was impossible for us
to use hierarchical
clustering because
of the high resolution
of our image.
So in this video, we
will try to segment
the MRI image using the
k-means clustering algorithm.
The first step in
k-means clustering
involves specifying the
number of clusters, k.
But how do we select k?
Well, our clusters would ideally
assign each point in the image
to a tissue class.
Or a particular
substance, for instance,
grey matter or white
matter, and so on.
And these substances are known
to the medical community.
So setting the
number of clusters
depends on exactly
what you're trying
to extract from the image.
For the sake of our example,
let's set the number
of clusters here, k, to five.
And since the k-means
clustering algorithm
starts by randomly assigning
points to clusters,
we should set the
seed, so that we all
obtain the same clusters.
So let's type set.seed,
and give it a value of 1.
To run the k-means clustering
algorithm, or KMC in short,
we need to use the
k-means function in R.
And the first input is whatever
we are trying to cluster.
In this case it is
the healthy vector.
The second argument is
the number of clusters,
and we can specify it
using the argument centers,
and that would be equal to k.
And then finally, since the
k-means is an iterative method
that could take very
long to converge,
we need to set a maximum
number of iterations.
And we can do this
by typing iter.max,
and give it, for
instance, the value 1,000.
And now let's run the
k-means algorithm.
The k-means algorithm
is actually quite fast,
even though we have a
high resolution image.
Now to see the result of the
k-means clustering algorithm,
we can output the structure
of the KMC variable.
The first, and most important,
piece of information
that we get, is
the cluster vector.
Which assigns each intensity
value in the healthy vector
to a cluster.
In this case, it will
be giving them values 1
through 5, since
we have 5 clusters.
Now recall that to output
the segmented image,
we need to extract this vector.
The way to do this is by
using the dollar notation.
For instance, let us
define healthyClusters,
and then set it
equal to KMC$cluster.
And what we're
basically doing here
is that we are taking
the information,
extracting the information
of the cluster vector,
and putting it in
the new variable that
is called healthyClusters.
Now how can we obtain
the mean intensity value
within each of our 5 clusters?
In hierarchical clustering, we
needed to do some manual work,
and use the t-apply function
to extract this information.
In this case, we have
the answers ready,
under the vector centers.
In fact, for instance,
the mean intensity value
of the first cluster is 0.48,
and the mean intensity value
of the last cluster is 0.18.
We can also extract this
information using the dollar
sign.
For instance, KMC$centers[2].
This should give us the
mean intensity value
of the second
cluster, which is 0.1.
And indeed, this
is what we obtain.
Before we move on, I would
like to point your attention
to one last interesting
piece of information
that we can get here.
And that is the
size of the cluster.
For instance, the largest
cluster that we have
is the third one, which
combines 133,000 values in it.
And interestingly,
it's the one that
has the smallest mean
intensity value, which
means that it corresponds to
the darkest shade in our image.
Actually, if we look at all
the mean intensity values,
we can see that they
are all less than 0.5.
So they're all
pretty close to 0.
And this means that our
images is pretty dark.
If we look at our image
again, it's indeed very dark.
And we have very few points
that are actually white.
Now the exciting part.
Let us output the segmented
image and see what we get.
Recall that we first
need to convert
the vector healthy
clusters to a matrix.
To do this, we will use
the dimension function,
that takes as an input the
healthy clusters vector.
And now we're going to
turn it into a matrix.
So we have to specify using the
combined function, the number
of rows, and the number
of columns that we want.
We should make sure
that it corresponds
to the same size as
the healthy matrix.
And since we've forgot the
number of rows and the number
columns in the
healthy matrix, we
can simply use the nrow and
ncol function to get them.
So the first input
right now would
be nrow of healthy matrix.
And then the second
input would be the number
of columns of the
healthy matrix.
And now we are assigning these
numbers of rows and columns
to our new matrix,
healthy clusters.
And now we can
visualize our clusters
by using the function image,
which takes as an input
the healthy cluster's matrix.
And let's turn off the axes.
And then let's be creative
and use a fancy color scheme.
We're going to invoke for color
here, the rainbow palette in R.
And the rainbow palette,
or the function rainbow,
takes as an input the number
of colors that we want.
In this case, the
number of colors
would correspond to
the number of clusters.
So the input would be k.
And now let's output
the segmented image.
Going back to the
graphics window,
we see that k-means
algorithm was
able to segment the image
in 5 different clusters.
More refinement maybe needs
to be made to our clustering
algorithm to
appropriately capture
all the anatomical structures.
But this seems like a
good starting point.
The question now is, can we use
the clusters, or the classes,
found by our k-means algorithm
on the healthy MRI image
to identify tumors in another
MRI image of a sick patient?
We will see if this is
possible in the next video.